Professor John
Rogers: Traditionally in
Renaissance literature,
the muses -- and this will be
familiar to many of you -- the
muses are thought to be the
daughters of Memory,
and the nine muses up on Mount
Helicon -- that's where the
muses are believed to have lived
-- are the offspring of the
goddess of memory,
whose name in the Greek is
Mnemosyne.
Mnemosyne, whose name is
spelled with some difficulty,
is spelled on the lower part of
your handout.
Now, there's an important
reason for this genealogy,
the idea that the muses are the
daughter of Mnemosyne,
the goddess of memory.
In the Renaissance,
the most potent source of
poetic inspiration was often
believed to be the poet's own
memory,
the degree to which the poet
could call up,
just out of sheer recall,
literary topoi or
commonplaces stored in his or
her memory from a lifetime of
reading.
Milton himself,
and this seems to be true,
is said to have had one of the
most capacious,
one of the largest memories in
English letters.
This is the effect that we get,
I think, from reading Milton --
is this notion that he seems to
have had one of the largest
memories imaginable and that
he's remembered just about
everything he's ever
read.Now we know that Milton
was blind probably well before
the time he began writing
Paradise Lost,
and therefore,
of course, he was then unable
to read.
Even though there were people,
mostly young men,
willing and able to read to
him,
it's clear that the vast
quantity of learning that gets
poured -- all of that erudition
that gets poured into the pages
of Paradise Lost -- it's
clear that this is not a product
of Milton's last-minute review
of the classics.
This learning springs from the
recesses of Milton's memory.
I take this to be an undeniable
fact, but this is easy for us to
say -- it's easy for us to say
that it's Milton's memory which
is the fount of so much of the
poem's erudition.
It's easy for us to say that it
was Milton's memory that
facilitated his grasp of the
Christian and the classical
traditions.But I think
Milton would probably feel a
little uncomfortable with our
easy attribution of so much of
the poem's learning to his
memory.
That's because to suggest --
just think of it -- to suggest
that Milton is relying on his
memory as he composes so
allusively and so dependently,
in a lot of ways,
so much of Paradise Lost --
to say that is simply to say
that the poem has been generated
by Milton and not by God.
Milton has expended,
we know, a considerable amount
of energy in establishing what
he wants us,
I am assuming,
to believe is the divine
authority behind the poem.
This poem, Milton tells us
again and again,
has been authorized by that
same Holy Spirit who had
inspired Moses to write the Book
of Genesis.
And so in order to make an
extraordinary claim for divine
authorization,
Milton has to defend against
this notion that I just began
this lecture with:
the idea that memory is on some
level really at the source of
Milton's poetic inspiration
because to rely on memory is
simply in some sense is to admit
that this is just one more epic.
It's to admit that this is in
fact a late epic and that it
derives from a close,
studious, student-like
imitation of the great epics of
Homer and Virgil.Now you'll
remember from our discussion of
the opening invocation to
Paradise Lost,
that insistent bid that
Milton was making:
the bid to be first.
His adventurous song is one
that "with no middle flight
intends to soar / above th'
Aonian Mount,
while it pursues things
unattempted yet in Prose or
Rhyme."
And so it was with such pride
that he declared that this poem
was going to soar above all of
its classical predecessors,
but the category [laughs]
"Prose or Rhyme" is a large
one.
It covers just about
everything, I would have to say,
and the literary spectrum from
prose to rhyme,
of course, would have to
include the Bible as well.
There's even the suggestion
here that Milton will be
pursuing things unattempted yet
even in holy scripture.
That is an extraordinary claim
for the poem's
originality.But it's a
difficult claim because even as
Milton makes this claim,
he manages to undermine its
force.
Merritt Hughes usefully notes
this in one of the notes at the
bottom of the page,
that Milton in that line,
"things unattempted yet in
Prose or Rhyme," Milton's
actually alluding to the opening
of another romance epic.
This is the Orlando Furioso
by the great
sixteenth-century Italian poet
Ariosto.
What is happening?
[laughs]
Milton had borrowed this claim
for an absolute originality.
He's taken it from somebody
else, and in doing so I think
he's doing this deliberately;
he's exposing some of the
darker ironies behind his own
literary ambition.
It's a good sort of question
that gets raised in such a
problematic allusion:
how do you set out to write an
original poem within such a
conventional genre like the
epic?
What does it mean to be
inspired to write by the
Christian Holy Spirit when your
epic,
in fact, just imitates a whole
array of classical pagan
conventions?
How can you write an original
poem when your literary
consciousness is essentially
made up of the memory of all the
things that you've read
before?This is what I'll be
proposing over the course of
this lecture:
that memory is a problem that
Paradise Lost is
continually confronting.
So much of the pathos of
Satan's fallen condition
involves his painful memory of
that blissful state in heaven
from which he had fallen.
The problem of memory is just
as important to the
psychological dynamics of the
fall of Adam and Eve,
but as we will see when we look
at Book Four,
surely it's the problem of the
poet's memory that's the most
troubling in Paradise Lost.
Milton's own faculty of
memory -- this is the idea that
I'm going to be floating here --
seems to provide something like,
or pose a stumbling block or an
obstacle for,
his attempt to write an
original,
divinely inspired poem.
I want to suggest in this
lecture something that will
initially sound,
I assume,
like a peculiar formulation:
there's a strange way in which
Milton has to imagine himself
losing his memory if he's
actually going to open himself
up to the muses' inspiration and
the inspiration of the
Christian,
the heavenly, muse.
There's a sense in which Milton
will have to forget everything
he's learned up to this point.
There are some important signs,
I think, especially in the
first two books of Paradise
Lost of what we can think of
as Milton's -- it's a literary
fantasy,
a literary fantasy of
forgetfulness.As you may
well have gleaned from your
reading,
the first books of the poem are
particularly absorbed with the
idea of forgetting,
because more than any other
part of Paradise Lost
they display so
ostentatiously the remarkable
scope of Milton's own memory.
These books are without
question more heavily allusive
than any other books in the
epic.
They are steeped in the entire
literary tradition of the
underworld journey that
stretches from The Odyssey
of Homer up through Virgil's
Aeneid,
and of course up
through all of the Renaissance
romance epics.
And it's important to remember
that Milton will -- this is
probably an invariable truth,
but I'll qualify it nonetheless
-- that Milton will typically
imitate his predecessors only
with a difference.
He usually takes pains (for
example, in his great depiction
of hell in Books One and Two) to
avoid the standard epic scenes
of the torture of the damned,
for example,
with which we're familiar if
we've read Homer or Virgil or,
of course,
Dante much later.There are
nonetheless a few details from
the classical underworld that he
seems to have lifted more or
less wholesale and one of them
-- I'm going to ask you to look
at page 246 in the Hughes.
This is line 582 of Book
Two.
One of these little details
that Milton has lifted rather
directly is that of the river
Lethe,
the river of oblivion that was
believed to flow in the
underworld.
It's a river that,
I think, all classical writers,
and a lot of Renaissance
writers, are very comfortable
placing in the underworld.
So this is Book Two,
line 582, Milton:
Far off from these a slow
and silent stream,
Lethe the River of
Oblivion rolls Her wat'ry
Labyrinth, whereof who
drinks,Forthwith his former
state and being forgets,
Forgets both joy and
grief, pleasure and pain.
So in this context,
the river of oblivion serves an
obvious purpose in the context
we have here in Book Two.
To drink from this river would
allow the fallen angels to
forget their fallen state,
to forget the fact of their
fallen-ness from their more
blissful former condition.
On some level,
forgetfulness would just ease
the grievousness of this
miserable new psychological
dynamic with which they are
tormented.But there's also,
I think, a deeper sense in
which Milton himself might want
to drink from this slow and
silent stream.
If Milton could silence -- see
what you think of this -- all of
his literary memories,
perhaps he could better
guarantee his fresh intake of
inspiration from the Christian
heavenly muse.
It's a fantasy,
of course, because no such
brainwashing is going to be
possible,
just as the fallen angels -- if
you look at line 607 -- will be
barred from drinking their fill
of the river Lethe,
forgetfulness is impossible.
The fallen angels, they:
…
wish and struggle,
as they pass,
to reachThe tempting
stream, with one small drop to
loseIn sweet forgetfulness
all pain and woe,
All in one moment,
and so near the brink;But
Fate withstands,
and to oppose th'
attemptMedusa with Gorgonian
terror guardsThe Ford,
and of it self the water
fliesAll taste of living
wight, as once it fledThe
lip of Tantalus.
It's an amazing passage because
in a lot of ways,
I think, Milton is actually
directly enacting for us,
the reader, the impossibility
of such sweet forgetfulness.
As soon as he describes the
impossibility of forgetting,
a flood of classical figures
pours into his own narration.
They pour with such a force,
I think, that Milton permits --
I think this is a significant
rift that fissures or fractures
the otherwise seamless text that
we have in Book Two.
I'm convinced that there's
something very strange going
on.Standing in the Lethe of
Milton's hell is none other than
the classical figure,
the figure from classical
mythology, Medusa.
You know Medusa.
She has the power with her
snaky locks to turn men into
stone, and so this seems to be
unique -- I don't know of any
predecessor that Milton had for
this: Medusa,
having been placed by Milton in
the river Lethe,
in the Christian underworld,
can prevent,
of course, the fallen angels
from drinking the waters of
oblivion.
Such is her power.
But we have every right to ask
what Medusa -- this is a figure
from Greek mythology -- what
Medusa is doing in a Christian
hell.
There are, of course,
dozens of figures taken from
the texts of classical mythology
who are alluded to throughout
the first two books,
but invariably they appear,
just as Tantalus does in this
very passage,
within the context of a simile.
They're not actually present in
the real world of Milton's hell,
or if it's a pagan god who's
mentioned,
Milton will tell us that the
pagan god was just an early
manifestation of one of the
fallen angels.But at least
within the context of the
present narration,
the figures mentioned in
Milton's hell are all former
inhabitants of the Christian
heaven.
And the fallen angels
themselves -- Satan,
Moloch, Belial,
Mammon, and Beelzebub -- these
are all demons who were drawn
from the Judeo-Christian
tradition of demonology.
They've been clearly been
hurled into hell by a
Judeo-Christian deity.
So this little moment,
this Medusa moment,
we can call it,
is really quite strange.
In the midst of all of the
Judeo-Christian realism,
we have standing here a
decidedly pagan -- and I think
this is not uninteresting -- a
decidedly female presence.
You'll correct me if I'm wrong,
but I think I'm right to insist
that this is a unique phenomenon
in these books.I think
there's actually a reason for
this aberration.
Medusa can turn men into stone.
She subjects them to that
posture of absolute paralysis
that we've seen represented in a
number of the early poems.
The Lady, the Lady in Milton's
mask, was stuck to her seat in
the presence of the
Shakespearian magician Comus,
and Milton himself had claimed
in the poem "On Shakespeare"
that Shakespeare "dost make us
Marble with too much
conceiving."
Shakespeare can turn us to
marble because he can fill our
imaginations and leave us
incapable of thinking for
ourselves,
incapable of maneuvering
around, or moving around,
on our own.
I think it's possible to see
Medusa here as an emblem or some
sort of figure for a similarly
paralyzing power.
You could think of Medusa as
Milton's counter-muse.
If Milton's true muse,
or so he hopes or so he wants
us to believe,
has a Christian origin,
then this counter-muse is
unquestionably classical.
She's a daughter of Mnemosyne,
the goddess of memory,
and she represents that force
that prevents Milton from
forgetting all of the pagan and
all of the classical literature
that,
of course, he had spent so much
of his life reading.Now I
asked you to read for today,
and I'm hoping you remember
some of the reading,
the canto from Spenser's
Faerie Queene that
features the cave of Mammon.
The cave of Mammon is the home
of Mammon, the money god,
who stores in his cave all of
the wealth and all of the honor
that human beings spend so much
energy striving for.
Now Spenser's hero in Book Two
of the Faerie Queene is
Sir Guyon, and Sir Guyon
descends into Mammon's Cave --
it's a Spenserian underworld --
and it's in Mammon's Cave that
he is tempted by the money god
himself.
This little bit of the
Faerie Queene is
important for Milton in all
sorts of ways.
It's first of all a depiction
of an underworld,
and so it provides Milton with
an important Christian
representation of a hell.
In that respect,
it has a kind of priority over
the hells or the underworlds of
Homer and Virgil.
It also provides Milton with
the figure of Mammon who will,
as you will see over the course
of this semester become -- well,
here in Paradise Lost
he's one of the key fallen
angels in Milton's hell.
Mammon actually seems to
represent the Miltonic position,
or that position in the debate
in hell that seems to resemble
most closely Milton's own moral
temperament,
we could say;
and you'll see at the end of
this semester that Spenser's
cave of Mammon canto is even
more central to Milton's sequel
to Paradise Lost,
which is Paradise
Regained, which in many ways
is a more or less close
rewriting of Spenser's story
with Satan playing the role of
Mammon and Christ in the role of
Sir Guyon,
the hero.Now you also may
remember that we have already
run into Spenser's Mammon before
this point,
before Paradise Lost.
Mammon had surfaced -- I'm
testing your memories here -- in
the text of Areopagitica.
Because this is one of the most
famous passages in the treatise,
and it's not one that we
actually looked at for Mammon
himself,
I'm going to ask you to turn to
Areopagitica.
This is page 728 in the
Hughes, the right-hand
column.
This is where Milton began to
consider the problem of
temptation that,
of course, will become so
important to Paradise Lost.
Here though,
Milton is talking about the
temptation of reading classical
literature.
This is an argument that we've
examined before.
Read everything you can,
Milton insists,
because only then can you
overcome what he thinks of and
characterizes as the temptation
of reading.
So in the right-hand column of
728:
I cannot praise a
fugitive and cloistered virtue,
unexercised and unbreathed,
that never sallies out and sees
her adversary,
but slinks out of the race
where that immortal garland is
to be run for,
not without dust and heat.
[I'm going to skip a couple
lines here.]
…
[W]hich was the reason why our
sage and serious poet Spenser,
whom I dare be known to think a
better teacher than Scotus or
Aquinas [Scotus and Aquinas are
medieval philosophers]
describing true temperance
under the person of Guion,
brings him in with his palmer
through the cave of Mammon,
and the bower of earthly bliss,
that he might see and know,
and yet abstain.
Spenser's cave of Mammon is
central to Milton's
understanding of the Christian's
resistance of temptation,
the temptation posed in
Areopagitica by
scandalous and seemingly
non-virtuous books.
Spenser, Milton argues here,
knows the importance of reading
everything, the Miltonic
position.
However evil those books are in
and of themselves,
we have to read them so that we
might see and know and yet
abstain.Now this passage is
famous for a lot of reasons,
not least of which is that it's
wonderful.
It's juicy evidence that
provides for Milton's intense
fondness for -- we might even
think of it as a passion for --
this earlier English poet.
The passage is also famous
because in it Milton does
something that he almost never
does.
Milton has made a mistake.
John Milton has made a mistake.
He's made a literary mistake
and, as I think all editors
know, Spenser does not.
Edmund Spenser in the Faerie
Queene does not bring Sir
Guyon with his palmer through
the cave of Mammon.
Guyon descends in to the cave
of Mammon by himself.
The palmer has been Guyon's
guide up to this point,
his teacher.
The palmer accompanies him on
all of his adventures but this
one, and Spenser in stanza two
of this canto makes a big deal
of the fact that Guyon is
descending in to the Cave of
Mammon by himself.
He's been separated from his
guide, his teacher,
the palmer.Milton seems
actually to have forgotten
something is.
His memory has failed him and,
given the general importance
that I'm attributing to problems
of remembering and forgetting,
I think it's safe to assume
that something important is
going on here.
The temptations that Mammon
offers Guyon are literally
within the story itself
temptations of wealth,
but they're also temptations to
the wealth of classical
learning, the wealth of the
entire classical heritage.
You'll remember that Mammon has
a special place within his cave
that's called the garden of
Proserpine,
and the Garden of Proserpine
has within it all of the central
symbols of pagan wisdom and of
beautiful epic literature.
Perhaps you'll remember,
too, that Tantalus is present
in the cave of Mammon,
literary temptation being as
important as all other
temptations in this canto of
Spenser's.
The temptations of classical
literature are so genuinely
tempting to Milton that he finds
it impossible to imagine that
Guyon could have seen and known
and yet abstained from them
without the aid of his teacher,
the palmer.You'll note in
this passage from
Areopagitica that Milton
himself calls Spenser a teacher.
He's a better teacher than
Scotus or Aquinas,
and the text seems almost to
suggest that Milton can't do
without his own teacher,
Edmund Spenser.
Milton needs Spenser -- this is
an argument that's been
amplified at some length and
really quite brilliantly by John
Guillory in the book Poetic
Authority -- Milton needs
Spenser to serve as the
Christian poet who can help
Milton fight off the temptations
of pagan poets like Homer and
Virgil;
or perhaps Spenser is a poet
who can help Milton fight off
the temptations of even a
secular contemporary like
William Shakespeare.
It's almost as if the story of
Mammon's temptations of Guyon
has hit a raw nerve in Milton.
Milton's lifelong
susceptibility to this story,
and that will without question
prove to be the case,
speaks to a truly profound
ambivalence about the pleasure
to be derived from a reading of
secular literature.
Milton seems genuinely
ambivalent about all of the time
and all of the study that he has
invested in his own education to
become an epic poet.
I think that the metaphors of
investment here and of profit
are especially applicable since
it's the figure of Mammon who
provides Milton with a literary
version of his economic account
of poetic investment and poetic
profit.Let's look at the
first appearance of Mammon in
Paradise Lost.
This is page 228 of the
Hughes, Book One,
line 678.
Milton's describing the
landscape of hell,
and hell here,
it turns out,
seems to resemble Milton's
heaven in that it contains deep
within it -- and we would never
have expected this -- it
contains deep within it a soil
that is hiding precious metals.
This is an underworld,
of course, but there seems to
be another underworld resting
just beneath it.
It's an underworld filled with
gold that a brigade of fallen
angels begins to extract with
spades and pick axes.
So this is what Milton tells us
at line 678:
Mammon led them on [this
angelic brigade]Mammon,
the least erected Spirit that
fellFrom
heav'n…
And even in heaven,
we're told Mammon was always
looking down [laughs]
-- it's kind of a cute scene --
Mammon was always looking down
at heaven's golden pavement
rather than contemplating the
more elevated figure,
presumably, of the heavenly
father.
And in line 684 we are told
this of Mammon:
…
[B]y him firstMen also,
and by his suggestion
taught,Ransack'd the Center,
and with impious
handsRifl'd the bowels of
thir mother EarthFor
Treasures better hid.
Soon had his crewOp'nd into
the Hill a spacious woundAnd
digg'd out ribs of Gold.
When we consider the degree of
Milton's anxieties about his own
attachment to classical
learning,
I think we can see the
significance of Mammon's actions
here.
The image of men,
and it's a grotesque image,
of men rifling the bowels of
their mother earth for treasures
better hid -- this is a
disgusting and terrifying image
of a lot of things.
One of the things,
I think, that it's an image of
is the practice of literary
excavation.
To ransack the intellectual
treasures hidden away in the
landscape of literary history is
an act, on some level,
of a kind of a violent
desecration.
Milton, I think,
would need to defend himself
from the implications of this
act of violence.And so
Milton calls on none other than
his teacher,
Spenser.
Milton seems to have dug around
rather carefully in his copy of
the Faerie Queene,
and he's come up with this
illusion.
You actually see this near the
top of your handout,
the allusion from the Faerie
Queene.
It's the passage from
Spenser's cave of Mammon
canto that describes this
same scene of violation,
the violation of mother earth.
The first discovery of gold for
Spenser took place when "a
cursed hand, the quiet womb / of
his great-grandmother with steel
to wound…"
Spenser, just like Milton after
him, seems to be associating the
digging of gold with the pursuit
of a very literary past.
They're on the same wave length
here.Now it's not entirely
clear that Milton has been
successful in sufficiently
vilifying Mammon's project of
the excavation of riches.
I think in a lot of ways -- and
this could probably be said of
Spenser as well -- Milton is
attracted to the excavation
project.
Look again at the sentence that
I just read, the last lines:
Soon had his
crewOp'nd into the Hill a
spacious woundAnd dig'd out
ribs of Gold."
The fallen angels may be --
okay, they may be violating
mother earth,
not so great,
but look what this violation
produces.
Out of the wound are dug "ribs
of gold."
The image that seems initially
negative begins to resemble
something, I think,
quite important and quite
beautiful.
I'm thinking here of the
creation of Eve.
Adam will tell us later -- this
is in Book Eight when Adam
recounts for us the creation of
Eve -- that God:
…
op'n'd up my left side,
and tookFrom thence a
Rib…[W]ide was the
wound…[but t]he Rib
He form'd and fashion'd with his
hands.
And when we remember that God
will dig a rib out of Adam's
wound in order to create the
beautiful,
the golden Eve,
we realize how complicated,
how complex and how ambivalent,
Milton's little image is here
at the beginning of the poem.
Milton is loading every rift of
this passage with ore,
and there seems to be something
at least provisionally -- at
least for a moment,
there seems to be something
potentially redemptive and
potentially generative about the
activity of excavation that
Milton is describing otherwise
so negatively here,
that he's condemning here.
Mammon uses this extracted gold
to create that magnificent
structure Pandemonium,
and the function of this
structure is implicit in its
name.
Pandemonium comes from pan
daimonium:
pan-demon.
It's the place where all of the
demons, all of the fallen
angels, will congregate.
This is their political capital.
This is where they will debate
their future and establish a new
political institution.
This structure -- and this is
something that's important for
Milton to convey to us -- is
genuinely beautiful.
It's not entirely clear that
Milton wants us to think of
Pandemonium as unambiguously
evil.
Clearly, it's evil in all sorts
of ways.
This is the fallen institution
established by the fallen angels
-- but it's more complicated
than that.
Look at Milton's description of
the architect of Pandemonium.
This is the man who appears as
the fallen angels enter the
building at line 732.
The architect of Pandemonium is
Mulciber and:
[H]is hand was
knownIn Heav'n by many a
Tow'red structure high,Where
Scepter'd Angels held thir
residenceAnd sat as
Princes...
Mulciber was famous in heaven
for building beautiful palaces
there, and Milton lets us know
that there isn't actually that
much of a difference,
at least in terms of
architectural or aesthetic
quality, between the palaces of
heaven and the palaces of hell.
For a moment at least,
it's almost as if there were a
strange moral equivalence
between the palaces up there and
the palaces down here.
A lot of the rigid moral
distinctions that the poem has
actually been working rather
hard to establish are beginning
to blur.
The line between good and evil
is beginning to blur.
Look at Milton's account of
what happened to Mulciber later
on earth.
This is line 739:
Nor was his name unheard
or unador'dIn ancient
Greece;
and in Ausonian landMen call'd
him Mulciber;
and how he fellFrom Heav'n,
they fabl'd,
thrown by angry JoveSheer
o'er the Crystal Battlements:
from MornTo Noon he fell,
from Noon to dewy Eve,A
Summers day;
and with the setting
SunDropt from the Zenith
like a falling Star,On
Lemnos th' Ægean
Isle…
Milton tell us that the story
of Mulciber in ancient Greece --
in Homer's account of The
Iliad, he tells us
this story.
It's actually the Homeric
version of the story of Mulciber
that you have reproduced for you
on the handout.
Milton is reminding us with
this illusion of the punishment
of Mulciber and the punishment
by implication of all of the
fallen angels by an angry God;
but at the very moment that
he's telling us of Mulciber's
punishment, he's allowing
himself to dilate,
to augment or to expand,
this beautiful little nugget
that's been excavated from the
pages of Homer,
and he allows himself to linger
over its beauty.
Just look at those lines again:
[F]rom MornTo Noon he
fell, from Noon to dewy
Eve,A Summer's day.
I propose that for a moment,
we almost forget what's
actually being described in the
passage.
It's as if the story of
Mulciber's punishment has come
to a standstill.
Of course, it's with no small
help from Milton's incredibly
elastic blank verse here that
the headlong rush of Mulciber's
fall has been drawn to a
provisional stop.
It's been drawn out and
spatial-ized.
It's as if it's been
spatial-ized into a scene of a
beautiful summer's day,
and we're left contemplating
not the punishment of evil but
-- I don't know,
one of the things we're left
contemplating is the sheer
beauty of Homeric poetry.
Milton has dug up a gem from
the pages of The
Iliad, and this gem
has something like a Medusa
effect on the poem or perhaps on
us as readers.
Time almost seems to stop when
we begin appreciating this image
solely on aesthetic
grounds.But Milton,
of course, is a Christian poet,
and he will not allow time to
stop forever;
for as soon as he explains that
Mulciber fell like a star on
Lemnos, the Ægean Isle,
he adds this:
[T]hus they
relate,Erring;
for he with this rebellious
routFell long
before…
This is so mean.
Just as we were beginning to
appreciate the loveliness of the
classical tradition,
Milton reminds us -- once again
he reestablishes the moral poles
of good and evil:
"hus they relate,
/ erring."
Who cares?
Who cares what Homer says?
What did Homer or any of
Homer's contemporaries know
about Mulciber?
Mulciber fell long before Homer
because Mulciber fell long
before the creation of the earth
-- and it's Milton,
and it's no other poet before
Milton, who's finally able to
set the record straight.
Milton's insisting here that
all of the pagan deities had
originally been fallen angels.
He's providing us with
something of a prehistory of
classical mythology,
a prehistory of classical
mythology that had,
of course, been completely
unknown to Homer and Virgil,
naturally, because they didn't
have the benefit of the
Christian story of the fall of
the rebel angels.Now without
doubt this is a dubious theory
of classical anthropology.
Milton probably knows that;
but it's a theory that serves
an obviously useful function for
Milton.
It allows the poet to
appropriate all of the classical
literature that he wants to
because in the end he'll be able
to correct that literature.
He can compare the myths of
Homer -- the earliest myths we
have -- he can compare them
directly to the time scheme of
Christian history and prove
beyond a shadow of a doubt that
his own version,
that Milton's own version,
of the story comes first.
Milton may be writing after
Homer, but the story he's
telling comes first.
This is one of the primary
strategies that Milton develops,
especially in the first two
books of Paradise Lost,
as a kind of defense
against his dependence on
classical literature.Now
Milton may not be able to forget
Homer,
but he is able to correct Homer
or to preempt Homer.
Let's look at a later
manifestation of Mammon.
This is in Book Two, line 249.
This is page 238 of the
Hughes, Book Two,
line 249.
This is Mammon's speech during
the great consult in hell.
The subject of the debate has
been the nature of the fallen
angels' political future:
essentially,
the question is where do we go
from here?
Moloch, you'll remember,
is the military general who
will risk absolutely anything
for revenge.
Belial is the lovely
intellectual,
the intellectual seeking peace
and who prizes above all things
his intellectual freedom:
our thoughts,
as Belial puts it,
our "thoughts that wander
through eternity."
Mammon is the profiteer.
Mammon is the goldsmith's son
who wants to invest his talents
with labor and with hard work in
order to show a profit.
Mammon's advice is thus not to
seek revenge on heaven or to
give up, as Belial is
counseling,
in despair but to cultivate all
of the rich resources that we
have down here in hell.
So line 249 of Book Two:
Let us [this is Mammon]
not then pursueBy force
impossible, by leave
obtain'dUn&a
grave;cceptable,
though in Heav'n,
our stateOf splendid
vassalage, but rather
seekOur own good from
ourselves…[T]hough in
this vast recess,
Free, and to none
accountable, preferringHard
liberty before the easy
yokeOf servile Pomp.
And a few lines down Mammon
tells us that we will "work ease
out of pain / through labour and
endurance."
He's offering us essentially an
economic model that,
I think, we as readers of
Milton recognize.
This is the model of investment
and profit that had
characterized Jesus' parable of
the talents.
It's the model of investment
and profit that characterized so
many of Milton's own early
writings,
including that promise,
you'll remember,
to his fellow Englishmen that
he would one day produce a work
of literature that his
countrymen would not willingly
let die.Now for my money,
it's Belial who gives us the
most beautiful and the most
seductive contribution to the
debate in hell,
but it has got to be Mammon who
most resembles Milton himself.
It's Mammon that comes closest
to Milton's own -- this puritan
ethos of disciplined liberty,
hard work, and this kind of
absolute self-sufficiency.
In so many ways it seems that
Mammon is actually echoing a lot
of the political prose that
Milton had written a decade
before.
It's almost as if in the
character of Mammon,
we have Milton's parody of
himself.
That cry, "Let us seek our own
good from ourselves" -- it's a
perfect Miltonic tag for the
first two books of Paradise
Lost.
Milton is always seeking a
good from himself that is
morally superior to the good of
his classical predecessors.
Milton refuses the state of
splendid vassalage to a kingly
poet like Homer.
He's continually seeking a good
from within his own religious
and from within his own literary
sensibility.Now in these two
books we've seen Milton dig up
and discard just about the
entire [laughs]
tradition of epic poetry.
It's at the end of Book two
that Milton seems to complete
this process,
this process of a trashing of
his literary predecessors.
It's here at the end of the
second book that Milton is
finally ready to embrace the
poetics of his better teacher,
Edmund Spenser,
and out of nowhere -- and I
know that all first-time readers
of Paradise Lost are
surprised by this -- we have
Milton engaging the fine art of
Spenserian allegory.
So let me remind you of what's
happening.
Satan flies out of hell.
He journeys heroically through
chaos in order to find that new
planet that he had heard about
in heaven,
and he's stopped by a figure
who holds the keys to hell's
gate and who can determine who
is able to leave and who is able
to enter.Now it goes without
saying that Milton has not been
up to this point writing an
allegorical poem.
The creatures moving and
speaking have been actual
creations of the deity,
with the strange exception of
Medusa.
They have a substantial reality
within the fictional context,
the mimetic context,
of this epic.
These are angels.
They are individual creatures
who seem really to be in hell
just as they seem really to have
been in heaven;
but the figures of Sin and
Death, they are entirely
different animals.
They are mere personifications
of abstract ideas,
and it's not at all clear that
Sin and her son,
Death, exist as individual
entities in the same way,
or on the same plane,
that Satan does,
for example, or Beelzebub.
It's reasonable,
I think, to invoke Dr.
Johnson here,
Samuel Johnson,
who writes in his Life of
Milton that Milton's (I love
this) unskillful allegory
appears to be one of the
greatest faults of the poem.
Whenever Johnson is being
arrogant and mean about
Paradise Lost,
invariably he's on to
something,
and here he's telling us that
Milton's gone too far.
He's taken his allegory too far.
He permits a real character
like Satan to interact with a
merely allegorical or symbolic
character like Sin.
The effect for Johnson -- and
who can say that this is -- that
Johnson is wrong?
-- involves an awkward
collision of different artistic
modes and entirely distinct
planes of reality.I don't
know.
If you've ever seen a movie --
well, there are lots of movies
that do this;
one of the first movies that
did this was "Who Killed Roger
Rabbit?"
-- if that's something you're
familiar with -- in which the
interaction of real people with
what are called "Toons" in that
film is part of the film's
pleasure.
The boundary between different
levels of reality is crossed.
Milton's performing a similar
boundary-crossing aesthetic
gesture here.
Now it might be morally useful
to talk about the forces of Sin
and Death as if they were actual
moral agents,
but it makes no sense within
the mimetic narrative that
Milton has created for us here
in this realistic poem.
I think that Milton is acutely
self-conscious of the uncertain
status that these allegorical
characters that he has invented
have.
And so I'm going to propose
this: the idea that Milton's own
allegory, while it is a serious
allegory and it's performing all
sorts of work that I don't have
time to talk about,
is at the same time a critique
of allegory.Look at the
description of Sin.
This is line 648 on page 247 of
the Hughes:
Before the Gates there
satOn either side a
formidable shape;The one
seem'd Woman to the waist,
and fair,But ended foul in
many a scaly foldVoluminous
and vast, a Serpent
arm'dWith mortal
sting.
Now those of you who have taken
English 125 or any course that
has asked you to read Spenser
will recognize almost instantly
I think,
I hope, Milton's literary depth.
At the very moment that Milton
is beginning his own attempt at
allegory, he alludes to the most
famous allegorical character by
England's most famous
allegorical poet.
This is Errour,
the filthy dragoness who charms
us, or doesn't charm us,
in the first canto of the first
book of the Faerie Queene.
Like Milton's Sin,
Spenser's Errour is half woman,
half serpent,
and in a lot of ways she
embodies the very problem of
religious error.
Dr.
Johnson is right to suggest
that Milton's use of Spenserian
allegory only invites a
confusion of what are
essentially disparate and
irreconcilable categories;
but what Johnson doesn't seem
to understand is that the
confusion is precisely Milton's
point.
It doesn't make sense to speak
of sin and death as if they were
living entities capable of
action and actual influence,
as if they were living entities
moving about as agents in the
world.And why is that?
Within the perspective of
Milton's free-will theology,
sin can't exist as an external
reality.
It can't exist as a force that
conceives a human individual
from the outside without that
individual's consent because we
all freely sin.
No one can be compelled to do
anything within the Miltonic
theology of free will.
Sin can only exist as the
product of individual choices
that freely willing people,
like Adam and Eve or like Satan
before his fall,
make and for Milton to parse
the world into rigidly
determined categories like good
and evil,
or sin and virtue,
is simply to be guilty of
intellectual error.
This isn't how the world works
in -- this isn't the Miltonic
universe.
Milton is alluding so
unashamedly here to Spenser's
Errour because,
I think,
on some level he wants to brand
Spenserian allegory as an
erroneous literary
practice.Now we've seen
Milton do this before.
He uses -- and I'm thinking of
"uses" in a pejorative way -- a
poet like Homer to extract what
beauty he can from deep within
the Homeric minds,
and then he does that only to
turn on Homer with that
devastating dismissal:
"hus they relate,
/ erring."
He doesn't even give Homer the
credit of [laughs]
being singular in having
composed The Iliad.
"They" -- who's "they"?
He can't even bring himself to
say, "Thus he relates,
erring," so powerful is this
defense against Homer.
Homer was in error,
Milton told us,
and Milton called on the moral
voice of Spenser to help him
make that moral judgment against
Homer.
But one of Milton's projects in
Paradise Lost is to
effect his forgetting of all of
his literary precursors.
That means that he has to expel
from his system not just Homer,
not just Virgil and Dante,
but also his better teacher,
Edmund Spenser.
It's almost as if we can hear
Milton say, after he's given his
own really quite elaborate
display of allegorical poetry,
"Thus Spenser relates,
erring."Now in 1644 when he
wrote the Areopagitica,
Milton may have forgotten
that Spenser's Guyon did in fact
descend in to hell without the
help of his teacher,
the palmer.
For Milton then,
at least at that point in his
career, his literary career,
such a trip without a guide may
well have seemed unthinkable.
The temptations of the wealth
of classical literature
represented by Mammon perhaps
were too powerful to resist
alone;
but now in the 1660s I think
it's possible to see a way in
which Milton finally gets the
story right.
He realizes now that it is
possible, perhaps it is
possible, for the Christian poet
to descend into the literary
underworld alone,
just as it was possible for Sir
Guyon in the actual Faerie
Queene to descend in to the
cave of Mammon alone.
Milton surveys the wealth of
literary tradition before him,
and he resists its allure
without the help of any human
guide.
He can reject the beauty of
Homer, he can reject the beauty
of Virgil, but he can also
reject -- and this has got to be
an even greater challenge,
perhaps -- he can also reject
the help of his Christian
teacher, Edmund Spenser.And
so I'm going to leave you here
at the end of this lecture less
with a conclusion than with a
paradox.
I think that Milton in
Paradise Lost finally
remembers what actually happened
in Spenser's cave of Mammon,
how the hero triumphed alone,
but Milton remembers this
particular Spenserian story only
once he has successfully
forgotten Spenser -- only once
he has set aside fully his
teacher's style of
poetry.Okay.
That's it for today.
Next time reread for the third
time -- you will be repaid by
your dedication -- Books One and
Two, this time focusing on the
similes.
Also, as I mentioned at the
beginning of class,
read the essays by Stanley Fish
and Geoffrey Hartman.